truth is the beginning of every good to
the gods and of every good to man
the greatest wealth is to live content
with little
an empty vessel makes the loudest sound
so they that have the least wit are the
greatest babblers
false words are not only evil in
themselves they infect the soul with
evil
no one is more hated than he who speaks
the truth
[Music]
books give us soul to the universe Wings
to the Mind flight to the imagination
and Life to everything
wealth and poverty one is the parent of
luxury and indolence the other of
meanness and viciousness and both of
discontent
the right question is usually more
important than the right answer
for a man to conquer himself is the
first and noblest of all victories
[Music]
you can discover more about a person in
an hour of play than in a year of
conversation
the eyes are more exact Witnesses than
the ears
if you do not take an interest in the
Affairs of your government then you are
doomed to live under the rule of fools
wise men speak because they have
something to say
fools speak because they have to say
something
beauty lies in the eyes of the beholder
reality is created by the mind we can
change our reality by changing our mind
a good decision is based on knowledge
not numbers
the beginning is the most important part
of the work
if a man neglects education he walks
lame to the end of his life
good people do not need laws to tell
them to act responsibly while bad people
will find a way around the laws
knowledge without Justice
ought to be called cunning rather than
wisdom
opinion is the medium between knowledge
and ignorance
false words are not only evil in
themselves but they infect the soul with
evil
people are like dirt
they can either nourish you and help you
grow as a person or they can stunt your
growth and make you wilt and die
those who tell the stories rule Society
when men speak ill of thee live so as
nobody May believe them
courage is knowing what not to fear
education is teaching our children to
desire the right things
character is simply habit long continued
a house that has a library in it has a
soul
good actions give strength to us and
Inspire good actions in others
writing is the geometry of the Soul
to find fault is easy to do better may
be difficult
no wealth can ever make a bad man at
peace with himself
love is the name for our pursuit of
wholeness for our desire to be complete
the price of apathy toward public
affairs is to be ruled by evil men
[Music]
lack of activity destroys the good
condition of every human being
the heaviest penalty for declining to
rule is to be ruled by someone inferior
to yourself
I am the wisest man alive for I know one
thing and that is that I know nothing
the measure of a man is what he does
with power
ignorance the root and stem of every
evil
for everyone you meet is fighting a
harder battle
human behavior flows from three main
sources desire emotion and knowledge
we are twice armed if we fight with
faith
there are two things a person should
never be angry at what they can help and
what they cannot
[Music]
poetry is nearer to vital truth than
history
the direction in which education starts
a man will determine his future
he who commits Injustice is ever made
more wretched than he who suffers it
know how to listen and you will profit
even from those who talk badly
he whom love touches does not walk in
darkness
life must be lived as play
everything that deceives may be said to
enchant
attention to health is Life's greatest
hindrance
it is impossible to improve the world if
first the man does not improve
our Envy always lasts longer than the
happiness of those we Envy
virtue is the desire of things honorable
and the power of attaining them
there is in every one of us even those
who seem to be most moderate a type of
Desire that is terrible wild and Lawless
nothing more excellent nor more valuable
than Wine was ever granted mankind by
God
[Music]
music and Rhythm find their way into the
secret places of the Soul
the wise men will want to ever be with
him who is better than himself
you take the words in the sense which is
most damaging to the argument
any man May easily do harm but not every
man can do good
those who don't know must learn from
those who do
he who wishes to serve his country must
have not only the power to think but the
will to act
the evil never attains to any real
friendship either with good or evil
twice and Thrice over as they say it is
good to repeat and review what is good
wonder is the feeling of the philosopher
and philosophy begins in wonder
better a little well done than a great
deal imperfectly done
we do not learn what we call learning is
only a process of recollection
knowledge becomes evil if the aim be not
virtuous
the excessive increase of anything
causes a reaction in the opposite
direction
[Music]
he who steals little steals with the
same wish as he who steals much but with
less power
the mind is not a vessel to be filled
but a fire to be kindled
[Music]
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments